Here is my solution. Test is a function of the data l and the hypothesis h.
We first compute the mean and then the plus/minus term of the confidence intervals,
and if our actual hypothesis differs from the mean by less than the confidence interval size,
we return true, and that is a two-sided test,
hence the absolute involving the difference between h and m.
If we look at this, this logical expression at the bottom will only trigger,
if h deviates way too much more than c from m, and so it goes.
Down here is the output of our example from class. 201.5 was the mean.
1.366 was the size of the interval, and we got a false.
We don't believe h zero.
If I change my hypothesis to 201 and one will test again, we now get a true as a result of this test.
Great. You programmed confidence intervals and you programmed a hypothesis test.
That is actually really cool. If you programmed it, I bet you now really know how it works.